reductionism acknowledges from the
outset that I'm not looking at the whole
picture I'm only looking at part of the
picture but the reason I'm doing that is
because I really want to understand that
looking at the whole picture is too
complicated so when javi was trying to
understand how the body works
he focused in on the heart and he
realized that the function of the heart
is not to serve as the soul but to serve
as a muscular pump that pushes blood
around the circulation so I know that
your heart in my heart is not the seed
of my soul of your soul it's a pump does
that make it any less magical do I have
less respect for your heart of my heart
because I realize how it functions No
number one number two once you
understand how components function you
want to put it into the context of the
body as a whole one of the major
arteries that come out of the heart how
do they feed oxygen to the muscles of
the body etc etc etc so we want to do
reductionism in order to understand
particular components but then it's Paul
Allen is showing we need to put the
components together we need a new
synthesis and so we need to put it in a
larger context so that leaves the
residual issue is to what degree does
the acknowledgement that all mental
function including my religious beliefs
emanate from the brain people have
difficulty with it they want to think
there's a mind out there someplace that
carries on after I'm dead and that
mediates a lot of these spiritual values
and I don't find good evidence to
support that as far as I can tell all
mental functions from the most trivial
reflex to the most sublime creative
experience come from the brain we have
reason to believe that some aspects of
free will you are not consciously aware
of I don't think that necessarily means
that you're not free but you
consciously aware of it and the
background from that comes from a famous
experiment that Benjamin Libet did and I
forget what it was 1971 there abouts he
a subject to make a decision to move
their hand and to indicate by pressing a
button when they making that decision
okay and he had electrodes on the head
and it turned out that before I made a
decision to move my hand an electrical
potential appeared in my brain that
preceded my conscious decision to move
the hand so you can be aware of my
wanting to move the hand consciously
without my being aware of it that means
the decision was made unconsciously now
when Ben Libet came out with that it
shook up the scientific community you
think Freud would have been surprised
about that he said from the very
beginning much of our mental life is
unconscious we now know we make a lot of
decisions we choose our partner and part
of unconscious evaluations there are
lots of decisions that are made better
unconsciously then consciously conscious
decision making is very good when there
are two alternatives because you can
focus consciously very effectively on
one thing at a time
if you've got a lot of options this was
not my case but you have lots of women
who interested in you probably can
choose for many of them that decision
that you have to make is likely to be
more effective you make it unconsciously
so there is now a whole psychology
unconscious decision-making that is
emerging in part stimulated by the bets
adjust but also continuation of Freud's
you